[Music]
foreign
here we are going to showcase the seven
types of infected mutant forms of the
cordyceps fungi and also their life
cycle well in the game the species
originated in South America where it
mutated to spread to humans via diseased
crops in the series however it was shown
that the earliest incidents was recorded
in Jakarta in Indonesia in September the
3rd of the year 2003 and then spread
quickly worldwide in a matter of weeks
let's talk life cycle now the fungus
first evolved rapidly due to global
warming and I suppose were found in
crops therefore infecting humans who ate
that food then when they are inside the
human body the fungus multiplies and the
hosts go through four phases of
infection
stage one this happens within two days
of the infection where the victim
gradually loses High brain function
causing them to become hyper aggressive
and unable of reason or logical
reasoning stage 2 this happens within
two weeks during which the fungus begins
to change their Vision as a result of
progressive cordyceps fungal growth over
the head and face and the visual cortex
being corrupted they still retain a
rudimentary form of intelligence here
though
stage three after a year the infection
progresses scarring their faces and
blinding them causing them to develop a
rudimentary type of echolocation to
adapt gradually the eyes and nose are
replaced with a hard and floral
outgrowth of the fungi resembling a
brain that has been exploded if the host
survives for more than a decade they
will reach stage four they form rigid
fungal plates across the majority of the
bodies so in the final stage when the
fungus kills the hose the body of the
hose develops stock-like fungal
projections that produce infectious
spores infections can also be
transmitted by bites from the live holes
victims can only be infected when they
are living since the fungus is parasitic
and needs a living body and cannot
infect that once yet Dead Infected can
produce pores regardless of stage
now let's take a look at the seven types
of infected mutant forms of the
cordyceps fungi Runners they are humans
who transform within two days of coming
into touch with the cordyce's brain
infection they are distinguished by
their high speed lethargic assaults and
proclivity to crowd their prey like
swarms their skin is pale modeled and
scarred and their hair has begun to thin
out and fall out because the fungus
first attacks the eyes Runners have
impaired eyesight but retain most of
their human traits Runners unlike
survivors stand in a slum stands while
being still the second one stalkers
these are the second stage of the
infection they take between two weeks
and over one year to reach the stage
stalkers combine the speed and vision of
Runners with a savagery of clickers the
stalker's most distinguishable trait is
their croaking noise and the onset of
fungal growths on their head and face
leaving the hose with just one eye and
the development of a Proto echolocation
ability they are cautious when detecting
a victim as they will strafe and take
cover and stalk demonstrating their
agility and Reliance on stealth they
ultimately close in on their prey
earning the name stalker number three
clickers these are the ICONic third
stage forms where they have been exposed
to the fungus over a year now and they
have the strength that much exceeds that
of a human a normal man their features
are utterly distorted and disfigured by
the fungus that has grown from their
sick brain frequently living just a
mouth of sharp teeth and a face that
looks like your brain that has been
exploded clickers may move about by
using echolocation which creates audible
clicking and screaming noises to
identify source of a sound and also to
make their way around hence their name
they are sometimes found being passive
but will hunt a victim until they are
found when activated by sound or noise
number four bloaters bloaters are the
infected's fourth one of the rarest and
one of the most deadliest stages they
evolve and reach this stage after years
of exposure they are very powerful and
physically intimidating they are coated
in thick fungus that acts as armor
plating as a result their skin develops
enormous patches of scale life tissue
that glow in the dark forming mycotoxin
pouches that's around the entire body
which they can throw at victims bloaters
are extremely aggressive and really
resilient and durable but they are
rather slow moving and uncoordinated and
have less effective equal location
ability than Clickers
number five the shamblers shamblers are
an alternate fault stage that are
thought to have been formed as a result
of exposure to large volumes of water as
opposed to the normal dry settings in
which bloaters grow in shamblers are
Abominations that discharge gaseous acid
when they come into contact with a
victim they walk slowly at first but can
run if they hear something when
threatened they automatically release
birds of corrosive spores from their
bodies the fungal growth is so massive
that suppose cover their entire body
resulting in enormous head and torsos
covered in hundreds of Boss spores
number six the Rat King this diseased
Oddity called the Rat King is a super
organism made up of stalkers clickers
and bloaters linked together by the
cordyceps fungus the Rat King is the
most powerful known infected and as such
it can withstand massive amounts of
damage and can easily destroy whole
building flows and walls easily it
appears to have originated as a result
of being locked in a chamber so densely
packed with spores that when the fungal
growth flowered and spread The Afflicted
are fused into each other it then has
the combined traits and powers of all
the different forms and growth stages
and lastly the mycelium Network there is
another stage that the fungi can develop
into it is seen as a hidden but vast
network of mycelium branches that act as
a rudimentary Communications link it
grows and spreads from Dead Infected
bodies into the walls and the ground so
if a victim happens to come into a
contact with it let's say step on it or
touch it it will alert a group of
infected that are nearby in a passive
state to attack
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam